يعقد في العاصمه الاثيوبيه اديس ابابا
اجتماع طارئ لمجلس السلمى والامن التابع
للاتحاد الافريقي لبحث تطورات الاوضاع في
السودان ويعقد الاجتماع على مستوى مندوبي
الدول الاعضاء في المجلس وبمشاركه موسى فك
رئيس المفوضيه الافريقيه وذكر مصدر في
الاتحاد ان الاجتماع سيبحث سبل الحد من
تفاقم الازمه والعمل على استعاده السلام
والاستقرار في السودان
وكان الاتحاد الافريقي قد اصدر بيانا عرب
فيه عن قلاقه من الاوضاع في السودان ودعت
الى الهدوء وضبط النفس واعطاء الاولويه
للحوار لصالح عمليه التحول الديمقراطي في
البلاده كما حث الاتحاد الافريقي المجتمع
الدولي على دعم مبادره الاتحاد لوقف
القتال وارساء الهدوء في البلاد